i can only apologize for the situation
just 24 hours ago neil parish was
insisting he would stay on as an mp
despite being named as the man who
watched pornography in the commons but
now a u-turn a resignation and a
shocking admission the situation was
that that um i uh funnily enough it was
tractors that i was looking at and um so
i did get into another website um that
had a very similar name
um and i watched it for a bit which i
shouldn't have done
but my my crime my biggest crime
um is that on another occasion i went in
a second time
and that was deliberately that was
deliberate and was that in the select
committee or in the commerce chamber
that was sitting waiting waiting to vote
speaking in the commons last week neil
parish today blamed a moment of madness
and said he wasn't trying to intimidate
women through his actions
but after the accusations of what
happened in here were first made on
tuesday there was unhappiness in the
party that mr parish stayed silent
senior tory mps say it shouldn't have
taken three days for the culprit to be
identified and suspended it's a shame
that it took till friday afternoon
before the name was known i know
of colleagues who uh were the
suggestions were made it could have been
them and they and the trauma they've
gone through um it would have been much
better for everybody if the whip had
been suspended immediately
now be a by-election to choose a new mp
for this devon seat in the leafy
south-west it has a large conservative
majority but after a series of
government scandals opposition parties
will be campaigning hard i'm just
horrified really that someone would do
such an inappropriate kind of bizarre
thing in such a reputable institution as
the house of commons i'm a radiographer
other radiographers have been suspended
for such behavior he just got caught but
he shouldn't have been doing it in in
the in the place of work anyway don't
matter where you are and working i just
don't feel like it should be seen
especially there's women around back in
westminster the resignation has come at
the end of a week where sexism in
parliament had been in focus anyway
ministers insisting today they'll work
to strengthen the rules to root out bad
behaviour i'm not satisfied if anybody
coming to work in parliament whether
they're a staff or on the estate whether
they are a member of parliament feels
uncomfortable or threatened or harassed
and that is right that we look to
strengthen the processes those
protections for victims people that
might have experienced that
neil parish said today he was standing
down because of the damage being done to
his family and his constituency in
reality the most deep-rooted impact this
affair will have may be on public trust
in politics itself